يلجا معظم طلاب الجامعات الى العمل في
المقاهي او المطاعم او في تربيه الاطفال
لكسب بعض المال ولكن هذه الطالبه في جامعه
دوك بيل نوكس لجات الى التصوير الاباحي
تقول ليل ان هذه الطريقه هي الاسهل لكسب
المال لتغطيه تكاليف دراستها
الجامعيه فهو لا ياخذ الكثير من وقتها
ويعتبر المبلغ الذي تكسبه كبيرا مقابل
الوظائف
الاخرى تخصص ب في دراسه شؤون المراه وظهرت
في مقابله حصريه مع بيرز موران من سي ان
ان بعد ان كتبت مقالتها انا النجمه
الاباحيه الاولى في جامعه دوك وهذه هي
قصتي
بكلماتي قالت بيل نحن في مجتمع يضطهد
المراه يوميا يقال لنا ان ممارسه الجنس
ليست عملا جيدا وانه علينا الامتناع عنه
يقال لنا انه يجب علينا تغطيه اجسامنا
وهذا صحيح للنساء فقط كوني في مجال
التصوير الاباحي وكوني قادره على ان اكون
عاريه والاستقلال جنسيا يعطيني هذا حريه
مطلقه بشكل لا يصدق وتضيف بل ان 80% من
الحركه على الانترنت تذهب الى المواد
الاباحيه وتقول ان المجتمع الذي يشاهدها
هو نفسه الذي
ينتقدها